muchas
vamos a tener que cambiar de canal
el sexo elimina piedras en el riñón
las vitaminas curan tu falta de energía
si tienes diabetes
librarte del cáncer
con una canción
pero solo si le escucha sin audífonos
para que entre a tu cuarto a tu cuerpo
las vibraciones
todos los días nos encontramos
afirmaciones sobre tratamientos
afirmaciones que pueden ser falsas
erróneas como las tres dimensiones
ahorita
y afirmaciones que nos llegan por todos
lados en todas las redes sociales como
facebook twitter instagram
en medios de comunicación masivos en
servicios de mensajería instantánea como
whatsapp o a viva voz de nuestros seres
queridos
y los tratamientos a veces se ofrecen
tanto para curar como para prevenir y
pueden ser muy variados un tratamiento
puede ser un medicamento puede ser una
cirugía una terapia novedosa genética un
remedio casero uno natural una dieta una
terapia alternativa o un programa de
ejercicios o rehabilitación
y algunas de estas afirmaciones hablan
bien de los tratamientos como diciendo
si funcionan como las tres mentiras que
dije ahorita
a veces hablan mal de los tratamientos
como estas dos que ven ahí en una dice
que la quimioterapia es la gran
equivocación médica y la otra dice que
las vacunas causan autismo imagínense el
impacto que pueden tener estas dos
afirmaciones imagínense en la primera
una niña a quien le acaban de
diagnosticar leucemia
sus padres deshechos buscan lo mejor
para ella y de repente reciben un
artículo de un ser muy querido es cierto
eso nos puede hacer dudar y retrasar el
inicio del tratamiento de esta niña y
puede tener consecuencias gravísimas
el impacto de la segunda también mentira
se está viendo en todo el mundo por las
múltiples epidemias de sarampión que se
están viviendo y esto está obligando a
gobiernos estatales o gobiernos de
países a implementar leyes para tratar
de detener estos brotes de sarampión que
están existiendo
la realidad es que las informe las
afirmaciones pueden ser bien
intencionadas pero si son erróneas
pueden causar daño esa es la realidad
complican las cosas las redes sociales
en las redes sociales aumenta la
credibilidad de estas afirmaciones con
el solo hecho de tener un montón de
likes un montón de compartidos y a veces
se enfrascan en una burbuja ideológica
porque cada vez que le das like te llega
una sugerencia de un artículo similar y
te empiezas a enfrascar en una idea
hace algunos años no nos cuestionamos
qué pasaría si alguien que dude en las
vacunas que duda de las vacunas se mete
a facebook a buscar a ver qué dicen de
ellos entonces hicimos el ejercicio nos
metimos a facebook escribimos en la caja
de búsqueda vacunas vaccines en español
en inglés en culiacán en inglaterra
hicimos comparaciones y resulta que
cuando escribe las vacunas te salen
sugerencias entonces escribimos y nos
salieron estas sugerencias le picamos a
la primera
y enfermeras en contra de la vacunación
obligatoria
esta página en ese momento tenía 12 mil
seguidores le dimos like como ejercicio
y nos dio más sugerencias la primera
está que está ahí dice la verdad acerca
de las vacunas esta tiene 40 mil
seguidores
le dimos like nos dio más sugerencias
las primeras 5 que ven ahí no son de
vacunas la última que tienen a la
derecha así cuales ésta tiene un nombre
muy oficial centro de información
nacional para las vacunas tiene un
logotipo muy oficial y tenía 71 mil
seguidores en ese momento imagínense con
tres clics yo ya estoy juntando más de
100 mil personas encontrar la vacunación
este experimento hace cuatro años si
quieres saber qué pasó con esas páginas
la de la verdad acerca de las vacunas
desapareció
y la otra ya está certificado verificada
con la famosa palomita y tiene en este
momento más de 217 mil seguidores
llegó un punto en el cual te convences
porque dices no puede ser que 217 mil
personas estén equivocadas
te asombra la cantidad de gente que está
ahí y te asombran más las historias y
los comentarios que ponen
porque porque las anécdotas pesan más
que la estadística cualquier comentario
cualquier cuento cualquier anécdota te
va a convencer más el número que te
ponga en un lado de un efecto secundario
rarísimo que pudiera tener una vacuna
entonces si los comentarios afectan si
los comentarios te llegan cuando entras
a leer en internet un artículo de salud
lees los comentarios que ponen las
personas al final
la inmensa mayoría dice que se es más a
veces ni siquiera lees el artículo y no
más te vas al final a leer los
comentarios
a ver qué dice la gente
entonces los gigantes informáticos ya se
dieron cuenta de este problema y se
supone que están haciendo algo al
respecto facebook interés instagram
inclusive youtube inclusive lás los
donde ondean campañas como gang football
fans se supone que están haciendo algo
para mitigar este problema de la mala
información sobre las vacunas pero eso
es un solo problema las afirmaciones que
se hacen sobre la eficacia y la
seguridad de las vacunas y qué pasa que
con todo el resto de tratamientos que
nos llegan día con día afirmaciones
sobre tratamientos para nosotros poder
evaluar las afirmaciones sobre
tratamientos que nos llegan todos los
días necesitamos ser alfabetos en salud
esto implica tener la habilidad la
capacidad de poder acceder información
de salud y de los servicios de salud
entenderla evaluarla y aplicarla a mi
persona para tomar buenas decisiones
las poblaciones que tienen bajos índices
de alfabetización en salud participan
menos en programas de detección temprana
de enfermedades
tienen menos apego a tratamientos por lo
tanto tienen menos control de
enfermedades crónicas como la diabetes
el asma también tienen mayor índice de
comportamientos de riesgo como el
tabaquismo la drogadicción el
alcoholismo tienen más accidentes de
trabajo y también tienen más índices de
mortalidad entonces a menor
alfabetización en salud te cuidás menos
te arriesgas más y te mueres más pronto
esa es la importancia de es entonces que
pudiéramos hacer bueno desde hace algún
tiempo en el hospital pediátrico de
sinaloa hemos hecho actividades como
ésta
taller de tratamientos mágicos en el
cual poníamos ejercicios y había una muy
buena discusión de los ejemplos que
venían en redes sociales se ponían muy
bien los talleres y era bien curioso
como después de los talleres a los que
tenían facebook como amigos yo veía que
eran críticos con todo lo que se sube y
toda la cosa
tiempo después volvemos a las mismas se
necesita un esfuerzo muy consciente para
estar en ese canal de criticar y evaluar
es algo pasajero entonces también
hicimos una campaña
en esta campaña se llamaba comparte con
cuidado en el cual invita vamos a
cualquier persona que quisiera compartir
algo sobre la salud en facebook o en
cualquier red social que siguiera estos
cuatro pasos primero crítica por favor
lee lo normal de él o checa la fuente
esto lo que te pido segundo comprueba
sobre todo si es un tema controversial
en la salud
otras fuentes checa las páginas
oficiales si es algo cierto va a estar
en todas tercero incluye es decir no
compartas no más sin decir nada no más
para ver qué dice la gente como dicen
por ahí nomás para alborotar a la
bitachera no incluye porque te gustó te
gustó no te gustó estás de acuerdo no
estás de acuerdo comprométete con lo que
estás comprando es compartiendo y si
cruzas esos tres pasos entonces si
comparte y fue bien interesante porque
alcanzamos miles de personas en un par
de días apareció en blogs en españa esta
campaña se unieron un montón de
organizaciones tanto mexicanas como
españolas
pero vuelvo a lo mismo son esfuerzos
fugaces pasajeros esa campaña se hizo
viral y desaparece entonces necesitamos
algo sostenido que nos sirva para toda
la vida
tal vez una intervención temprana una
intervención desde la infancia y ahí es
donde entra el proyecto informe informe
health seis decisiones informadas censal
en este proyecto lo primero que se hizo
fue identificar qué conceptos clave debe
de entender todo el mundo para poder
evaluar esas afirmaciones que se dicen
sobre los tratamientos
después de identificados que gran parte
del trabajo de este proyecto tiene como
base es el libro que se llama testing
treatment cómo se paran los tratamientos
y ustedes pueden ustedes pueden
descargar de más de manera gratuita en
esa página que viene ahí abajo en inglés
en español o en el idioma de su
preferencia después de esto se hicieron
recursos educativos dirigidos a los
niños a manera de historieta como ésta
que ven aquí aquí ven a un niño que está
cocinando en la aldea llega el perico al
pueblo lo asusta y el niño se quema
entonces empiezan a discutir qué hacer y
el perico como repite todo lo del pueblo
dice que el estiércol de vaca cura las
quemaduras y la niña lo respalda si yo
he escuchado eso por lo tanto el niño
termina metiendo el dedo en el excel
ahí tenemos una afirmación el estiércol
de vaca pura las quemaduras y de ahí
parte la lección con los niños entonces
ya teniendo estos recursos se pusieron a
prueba se dividieron 120 escuelas en
uganda a la mitad al azar ya la mitad
les dieron estos recursos y a la otra
mitad no y este grandísimo estudio que
incluyó más de 10 mil niños niños que no
tienen el inglés como su primera lengua
se demostró que pueden entender desde
los 10 años estos conceptos cosa curioso
es que los papás también les enseñaron a
manera de podcast y un año después
evaluaron a los dos a los niños les fue
mejor y a los papás les fue peor
necesitamos desde temprano y aquí
estamos echando las ganas ya tenemos
traducido y validado el cuestionario que
evalúa el entendimiento de estos
conceptos y el equipo de españa ya tiene
traducidos todos los recursos educativos
y se va a implementar en tres escuelas
en barcelona
señores secretarios de educación señores
secretarios de salud esto lo tenemos que
implementar aquí en mí
no por hacerle publicidad a la librería
que tiene este eslogan que es un fondo
amarillo con unas letras lilas leer
evitará que es más o menos el mismo el
mensaje que yo les pudiera dar
el ser alfabetos en salud evitará que
nuestros hijos crean que las vacunas
causan autismo o alzhéimer o que el agua
tibia con limón y bicarbonato previene o
cura cualquier tipo de cáncer muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]